but you have become let's face it since
the uber investment since the Twitter
investment you become a bit of a legend
now you got the you have to shark hang
going life has changed a bit for you in
the last two years since you were on the
programmers Lobby here you hang out with
me now yeah you got me in the posse I'm
part of the squad you got a squad what a
perk that I get I mean just think Jay
Cal wouldn't have ever cared about Chris
Sacca no no no I think I passed him yeah
no offense in fairness you know where we
finally started getting know each other
was with the open angel forum that was
it that's true yeah we've known each
other we've been in the same circles but
I think once you started really hosting
those angel dinners yeah which were kind
of amazing you surfaced uber and style
seat and thumbtack and stuff like that
like yeah back up if I think we did we
sold so but I think that's where we
really started to hang out yeah and you
actually were in Cabin where the hosts
of it here in San Francisco
and by hosts I invited you and sent by
the way you're the host now really quick
yeah exactly that's that's it's such a
Jake I'll move really quick footnote I
don't know if you remember this but the
open angel forum what was that like peer
whatever where that was being they'll
hear that they shut everybody down but
it was at some twenty eight yeah so
we've got the open angel forum that
Kevin and I find out when we arrive
we're hosting yes
uber presents there yes do you know who
was coding about 25 feet away alone at a
desk
I don't Kevin Systrom of Instagram
hilarious he was the single employee of
bourbon I hadn't seen him since Google
and I went by I was like hey dude what
do you work it on and ended up being one
of the early investors in Instagram too
so I saw the being yeah and you remember
that also in addition to being a host
parking host as I get a 2% carry but
that's literally how that came together
he was sitting in the shadows
coding people to understand system
literally as much as these dresses all
prep read and stuff like that he's a
hacker and he cooked up all those
original filters himself and stuff but
he's a pretty interesting cat yeah no
doubt
but he was literally right there lurking
while your dinner was taking place